[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sens public vous le
savez la promesse est dans le titre de
l'émission donner du sens à l'actualité
vous proposz des clés de compréhension
des crises que nous traversons et voici
le sommaire de ce 4 décembre la France
de nouveau visée par le terrorisme
islamiste dans son quartier le plus
touristique la tour fel samedi un
Allemand de 23 ans à été tué de
plusieurs coups de couteau le coup de
couteau qui a été mis c'est fait pour
tuer hein c'est pas je vais vous faire
une petite Taillade là sur l'avantbras
non non cétait vraiment fait pour tuer
non non c'était préparé à mon avis
prémédité le ministre de l'Intérieur
parle d'un ratage dans le suivi
psychiatrique du suspect comment ce
Français d'origine iranienne était-il
surveillé après sa sortie de prison en
mars 2020 après 4 années passé derrière
les barreaux pour radicalisation quel
est l'état de la menace terroriste à
moins de 8 mois des Jeux Olympiques on
répond à ces questions dans une minute
et puis pour notre second débat
volontairement décalé de l'actualité du
jour je vous propose de revenir sur
cette polémique déclenchée par la
campagne de l'ADEM l'agence de la
transition écologique c'était il y a 15
jours des dévendeurs qui incitent à
acheté d'occasion juste avant le Black
Friday ce qui semblait une bonne idée à
provoquer la colère des commerçants et
des enseignes d'habillement déjà en
grande difficulté peut-on concilier
urgence écologique et croissance
économique ne ratez pas la confrontation
de nos experts sur ce thème ce sera dans
3ois/art d'heur mais d'abord ce que
l'enquête nous apprend sur le terroriste
de birakem et puis également les
réactions politiques avec Cécile
sixxou il n'y a pas eu d'erreur de ces
services après l'attaque du qu de Grenel
géralde daranin défend ses troupes
prison suivi judiciaire et surveillance
elles ont fait ce qu'il fallait le
maximum même pour éviter le passage à
l'acte de l'assaillant terroriste s'ilen
un loupé dit-il il est d'ordre
psychiatrique le suspect avait des
troubles mentaux il y a quelqu'un de
malade mentalement qui neend qui ne
prend plus ses médicaments qui ne prend
plus son soin pour soigner ses délires
et qui passe à l'acte incontestablement
il faut réfléchir à tout pour protéger
les Français c'est bien sûr le cas du
travail des services de renseignement
sur le cas dans la justice et ça va être
le cas évidemment dans la médecine
aujourd'hui 30 % des radicalisés sont
aussi malades psychiatriquement le
gouvernement aimerait dans ces cas
donner le pouvoir au préfet d'imposer un
suivi médical aujourd'hui seuls les
juges le peuvent chaque fois qu'un drame
comme celui-ci survient ça soulève à
nouveau la question de l'adaptation du
droit et de nos services d'action à
l'état de la menace par exemple se pose
la question d'avoir une prolongation de
l'inenctionction de soins lorsqu'il
s'agit de personnes qui cumulent à la
fois la pathologie psychiatrique et la
radicalisation un suivi jugé inutile par
Jordan Bardella pour le président dans
du RN le gouvernement fait diversion le
sujet ça n'est pas la psychiatrie le
sujet c'est l'islam radical voilà et je
pense que il est extrêmement dangereux
de détourner le débat et de créer une
polémique dans la polémique parce que à
la question ce type était-il
déséquilibré je pense que pour prendre
un couteau une kalashnikov et et et
abattre des gens dans la rue il faut par
principe être déséquilibré Jordan
Bardella plaite pour placer en rétention
de sûreté les prévenus jugés dangereux
il souhaite aussi l'expulsion systéma
des radicalisés et demande la démission
de géralde
Darmanin est-ce un ratage du suivi
psychiatrique ou policier où on est la
menace terroriste en France on en débat
avec Antoine jardin bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes docteur en sciences politiques
ingénieur de recherche NRS au centre de
recherche sociologique sur le droit et
les institutions pénales et vous êtes
également membre du conseil scientifique
sur les processus de radicalisation
Samia mactou bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
avocate au barreau de Paris vous avez
défendu de nombreuses victimes du du
terroriste Jérôme bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue enseignant prospective et
stratégie à science pour Paris et vous
publiez la prospective stratégique aux
éditions Herman et Mathieu croissand
bonsoir Mathieu éitorialiste
politique c'est vrai que quand on un
attentat survient on cherche toujours la
la faille Antoine
jardin est-ce qui n'a pas fonctionné
dans dans dans notre système de
protection est-ce que vous parlez comme
le ministre de l'Intérieur de ratage
psychiatrique c'est le terme qu'il a
employé B jeis pas si on peut dire
ratage mais ce qui se passe c'est que
une personne qui a été déjà condamnée
qui a fait 4 ans en détention qui est
sorti a réussi à recommettre de nouveau
un attentat donc forcément c'est quelque
chose dont on peut pas se satisfaire en
même temps il est impossible d'envisager
queil y ait zéro récidiv et que on
puisse prévenir à l'avance tous les
attentats on sait qu'il y a beaucoup
d'attentats qui sont déjoués ce qui fait
penser par ailleurs parfois qu'il y a
peu de tentativ alors que c'est pas le
cas il y a beaucoup de tentatives et
malheureusement certains individus
parviennent à le faire ici on avait en
espace une personne qui était particul
ulrement durement engagé dans les
mouvances jadistes h est-ce que vous
parlez de
de dysfonctionnement dans le suivi
thérapeutique ou est-ce que c'est une
façon de voilà de de gommer une part de
responsabilité du ministre de
l'intérieur ou de ses troupes dans tout
acte terroriste il y a dysfonctionnement
il y a dysfonctionnement et puisqu'on
parle de de de victime parce que
aujourd'hui il est il me semble plus
important de mettre le curseur sur les
attentes des victimes plutôt que
qu'est-ce qui a fait que cette ce
terroriste passe à à un acte et et de se
prendre le temps nécessaire pour
décortiquer
cette ce dysfonctionnement euh
psychiatrique même si on veut éviter
d'autres d'autres passages à l'ct il
faut quand même essayer de tirer les leç
de c'est certain mais aujourd'hui c'est
de radicalisation islamiste dont il
s'agit et non seulement et non seulement
de ce qui a poussé cette ce terroriste à
à passer à l'acte alors le disfon nement
oui il y a forcément un
dysfonctionnement et j'ai envie de dire
que de toute manière dans n'importe quel
état démocratique dans n'importe quel
état de droit le zéro risque n'existe
pas aujourd'hui on apprend de tous les
attentats moi j'ai envie de dire que
depuis 2012 depuis l'attentat de Mohamed
Mera où la théorie du loup solitaire a
été battu en brèche on a avancé on a
avancé mais il y a encore des trous dans
la raquette et c'est trou là qu'il va
falloir gommer pour qu'il n'y ait plus
de passage un acte terroriste et et
d'ailleurs ce sera l'un des thèmes de
notreat ça pose une vraie question un
vrai défi pour nos démocraties jusqu'où
on va jusqu'où on rogne sur un certain
nombre de liberté est-ce qu'on est
obligé de rogner sur ces libertés pour
augmenter le le niveau de de de sécurité
de de nos concityens Jérôme clè comment
vous analyser le profil de ce terroriste
français d'origine iranienne analyser le
profil c'est toujours très difficile là
on a affaire à quelqu'un qui est
vraisemblablement à la charnière entre
l'islamiste radicalisé et le radicalisé
euh islamisé c'est-à-dire avec un profil
psychiatrique qui l'aurait amené à faire
ressurgir ou à se draper d'une idéologie
islamiste laquelle n'a pas forcément été
prégnante au démarrage et il y a
peut-être quelque chose qui s'esttisssé
dans le temps j'en dirais pas plus pour
le profil parce que c'est pas mon
secteur mais ce que je peux dire sur la
façon de traiter ce genre de profil
c'est que vraisemblablement la partie
euh prédiction pour prédire le passage à
Act est encore plus difficile si
regardez les les mesures qu'il y a parce
qu'il y a ce profil psychiatrique mais
parce qu'il y a un profil psychiatrique
parce que si on parle de défaillance en
effet elle est pas du côté du
renseignement on savait tout 24 heures
plus tard on sait tout sur lui on sait
tout sur lui parce qu'on savait tout
déjà la question c'est pas de savoir
c'est de pouvoir prévoir or ce passage à
l'acte là il se tient à un profil qui
est hyper volatile dont le projet
terroriste s'arrime sur quoi sur des
armes qui n'en sont pas en réalité
c'est-à-dire des armes blanches il n'y a
pas d'armes à feu sont des armes lowcost
du tout venant c'est des cibles qui sont
des cibles d'opportunités qui
nécessitent pas un engagement une
organisation une complexité c'est
quelque chose une décision qui peut
avoir été prise quelques heures
peut-être un jour avant donc si vous
voulez pour qu'il a donc c'est d'autant
plus difficileti voilà pour qu'il y ait
une prévision à ce niveau-là il faudrait
qu'il y ait une surveillance H24 en
permanence or il y a une surveillance
administrative mais une surveillance H24
pour des profils hyper dangereux ce qui
n'était pas profil hyper dangereux qui
n'était pas pour une surveillance à 24
c'est 20 fonctionnaire pour un profil
hyper dangereux donc si vous voulez la
question de la surveillance ici est
assez vite réglé elle était effective
elle était autant qu'on peut surveiller
après ce qu'il aurait fallu en quelque
sorte et c'est ce qu'on demande en
quelque sorte j'is dire ce qui en
filigram des demandes c'est pas ce qu'on
demande mais c'est ce qui en filigram
des demandes c'est qu'on voudrait qu'
quelque chose une action préemptive
Minority Report si vous voulez mais ça
ça n'existe pas on peut pas prévenir
l'infraction avant l'infraction parce
que précisément la surveillance et le
renseignement ne peut pas aller au-delà
de cette limite qui est tant qu'il n'y a
pas de choses qui tombe sous le coup de
la loi on ne peut pas aller
au-delàend j'entends vos arguments enfin
on peut pas non plus se résigner donc
c'est il y a forcément une réponse
politique qui attendue des polémiques
politiques forcément
aussi pas c'est en décroissance et il y
a plus de de sans attentats dé joués par
an c'est les chiffres de 2022 alors il y
a forcément une réponse plusieurs
réponses du ministre de l'Intérieur
depuis samedi soir sa dernière réaction
c'était aujourd'hui on écoute Gérald
daranin une des difficultés c'est que si
la mère de cet assaillant terroriste
était venu évoquer le fait que son fils
qui avait une maladie mentale prononcée
et qui était dans l'islam radical in
contestablement ne prender plus ses
médicaments comme elle n'a pas voulu
déposer et qu'elle a pas voulu demander
son hospitalisation le ministère d'
l'intérieur est un peu limité dans son
action et donc je redis mon souhait de
travailler avec les parlementaires à
cette injonction de soins psychiatriques
que pourraient obtenir les préfets dans
les conditions voilà extrêmement
difficiles que nous avons à à gérer une
un certain nombre de personnes qui sont
dans l'islamisme radical et qui sont
atteints de maladie mentales et je crois
que il serait temps que le Parlement en
effet puisse donner les moyens au au
gouvernement d'agir sur ce point alors
voilà une première piste une première
solution proposée par le ministre
l'injonction de soins thérapeutiqu
Antoine jardin votre avis là-dessus
est-ce que c'est une solution ce serait
supposer que c'est la pathologie
psychiatrique de cette personne qui est
la cause de son acte ce qui est pas du
tout évident euh parce que en fait il y
a pas d'opposition entre être atteindre
une pathologie psychiatrique et être
idéologiquement adhérent à des thèses et
là on a en l'occurrence quelqu'un qui de
longues dates était dans des réseaux
djihadistes à rencontré en détention des
personnes qui étaient des militants
djihadistes donc ça date pas d'hier et
c'est pas un déclenchement récent le
fait qu'il soit passé à une logique de
violence puisqu'il avait déjà été
condamné pour préparation d'un attentat
donc c'est plutôt une défaillance de
difficulté de suivi de long terme qui
s'applique pas spécifiquement aux
personnes qui sont atints de pathologies
psychiatrique peut-être que ça peut
aider mais c'est s pas déterminant samou
moi sincèrement j'ai l'impression
qu'on enfin on donne la patate chaude à
d'autres pour ne pas assumer la
responsabilité qu vous dit vous parlez
du ministre de l'intérieur du ministre
de l'Intérieur aujourd'hui et pour
répondre à Monsieur le Professeur
lorsqu'on parle de cette pathologie pour
expliquer entre autres le passage à
l'acte et vous évoquez ses armes euh
vous avez évoqué la galaxie djihadiste
autour de laquelle tourne cette ce
terroriste ce terroriste appartient
depuis avant même sa condamnation à au
groupe terroriste forsanzard ce
terroriste était en lien avec des
terroristes qui ont commis sur le
territoire français je vais pas revenir
sur l'ensemble des terroristes condamnés
et et qui ont commis des ATT attentat
sur notre territoire donc nous avons
tous les ingrédients pour considérer que
nous sommes face à un profil dangereux
susceptible pour reprendre la
l'expression du renseignement
susceptible de passer à une action
terroriste et pour finir juste pour pour
vous convaincre si vous nêtes pas encore
suffisamment c'est que notamment et je
me citerai que les deux attentats commis
sur le territoire français à Nice en
2016 et en 2020 à Nice nous avions le
même profil psychiatrique et et pour
l'anecdote les les les avocats de la
défense qui est tout à fait légitime ont
même demandé une expertise psychiatrique
postmortem donc vous voyez que nous
sommes dans une stratégie Deo c'est une
façon de se dédoiner de de leur
idéologie et de leur responsabilité
parce que tout à fait et law boulel
prenait des neurolithiques et il avait
aussi des des prescriptions longues et
larg par son médecin depuis l'âge de 16
ans et euh sa famille a dit exactement
la même chose pardon comme j'étais dans
le dossier et c'est plus protégé par le
secret
euh de
l'instruction on se retrouve dans
exactement le même cas c'est pour ça que
je je ça me gêne un peu de déplacer tout
le problème sur le côté psychiatrique ce
n'est pas le cas le problème c'est une
radicalisation c'est quelqu'un qui a un
profil qu'on pouvait pas ignorer et le
c'est que quand il s'est présenté à la
police il a il a dit et on l'a cru qu'il
s'est autoradicalisé ou
autout déradicaliser et bon c'est vrai
qu'on on les croit pas assez mais en
tout cas moi je ne crois pas à
l'autodéradicalisation sont des profils
malgré tout compliqués peut-être qu' on
n pas exactement les bonnes grilles de
lecture en tout cas c'est ce que disait
ce matin Hugo Micheron spécialiste du
Moyen-Orient c'était sur France Inter on
l'écoute je me
méfie de cette approche qui qui viserait
en fait à à surpsychologiser l'individu
parce que souvent de de mon expérience
sur l'analyse des profils ce qu'on voit
derrière c'est une incompréhension de
l'idéologie l'idéologie djihadiste elle
est particulière entendre des voix et
cetera ça fait partie et là c'est le cas
aussi hein dans ce profil là on retrouve
des éléments apparemment il aurait eu
des voix il y aurait il interprété les
signes et cetera mais ça c'est des
choses extrêmement communs valorisé par
ailleurs par l'idéologie djihadiste
qu'on entend qu'on entend dans
différents
euh différentes déclarations enfin ce
sont des signes récurrents donc moi ce
que je dis c'est que l'analyse opsie
elle est fondamentale je ne peux pas me
prononcer en l'espace sur ce sujet- là
mais ce que je dis c'est que il faut
évidemment la combiner avec une solide
connaissance de la dimension idéologique
parce que si on prend de l'idéologie
pour de la folie bah on fait des erreur
de d'évaluation est-ce qu'on a la bonne
grille de lecture je reprends cette
cette expression là Jérôme clè
c'està-dire que effectivement il y a
cette approche psychologisante ou ou
psychiatrique tient-elle forcément
suffisamment compte de du contenu
idéologique
ou de la motivation profonde de ces
terroristes mais quand bien même elle
tiendrait suffisamment compte la
question ne se trouve pas là la question
si on le si on confie finalement ce que
nous dit je je je dis pas je suis
d'accord avec Jard Lam mais je reprends
son argumentation consiste à dire la
faille elle est de ce côté-là c'est il y
a pas eu d'injonction thérapeutique
suffisante il a pas été suffisamment
surveillé par les psychiatres et cetera
et ca supposons on l' laissé ne plus
prendre ses médicaments supposons que la
faille soit du côté administratif
c'est-à-dire sur la question du
renseignement typiquement que
pourrions-nous faire de plus sans
écorner sans écorner l'État de droit
voilà dans le dis dans les dispositifs
actuels que pourrions-nous faire de plus
le dispositif actuel la loi sur le
renseignement de 2015 qui permet à peu
près euh toutes les investigations
techniques par le renseignement sous
réserve que ce soit valisé par la SNCT
c'est-à-dire la Commission nationale du
contrôle des techniques de renseignement
ça a été renforcé par la loi de 2017 la
loi silt et encore par la loi en 2021
qui permet de faire de l'automatisation
sur la surveillance informatique
notamment qui permet un certain nombre
de croisement de fichiers à la faveur de
l'opsi web c'est-à-dire croisement de
fichiers psychiatrique qui arrive à
l'autorité administrative les préfet
éventuellement les services de
renseignement s'il est besoin donc si
vous voulez en terme de renseignement on
l'arsenal législatif on peut pas aller
plus loin la question c'est où euh donc
on baisse les bras et on dit bon ben
voilà s y des attentats comme celu d' on
arrive à une situation où on se
confronte à ce que vous dites à juste
titre le risque zéro n'existe pas et
tout ce qu'on peut faire de plus et sans
doute faut-il faire encore davantage va
nous amener à une solution qui est
asymptotique c'est-à-dire à faire tendre
ce genre d'acte terroriste vers zéro
dans leur nombre et a un impact toujours
plus réduit regardons la physionomie de
cet acte terroriste on n'est pas un acte
terroriste à grande échelle c'est
précisément pour ça qu'on narrive pas à
matérialiser le début d'une infraction
pénale qui nous pourrait permettre au
service de Rense ignement de le stopper
à temps c'est-à-dire de le confondre
dans une entreprise qui serait le début
d'une entreprise terroriste pourquoi
parce qu'il y a pas d'organisation
complexe de grande ampleur qui nécessite
ça c'est pour ça que vous parlez de
thérorisme locost pardon jeis vousedner
la parole tout vous voulez intervenir
mais je crois qu'on a en fait finalement
des structures très similaires entre cet
attentat et l'attentat d' ras où les
deux personnes étaient connues suivies
un entretien la veille dans le cas
l'attentat d' race et ça veut pas dire
que on peut empêcher à l'avance en
devinant à l'avance ce que vont faire
les individus donc on voit bien qu'il y
a un travail fort de service de
renseignement qui ont cette structure
d'information et il y a une limite à ce
qui est faisable et la question c'est
quelle est cette limite alors on
pourrait dire bah il faut sortir de
l'état de droit par exemple une personne
qui a été condamnée et qui a purgé sa
peine et bien n'est toujours pas libre
on pourraiter ça cont de de droit Cho de
sociéé on en est plus à des moyens
techniques qu'il faut pousser plus fort
dans leur degré c'est plutôt un choix de
société allez un mot encore et je parler
maie sur les réaction mot sur ce que
vient de dire le ministre de l'Intérieur
concernant la mère de ce terroriste qui
d'elle-même est allée vers la police
pour dire que mon fils a un comportement
euh bizarre donc lorsque le ministre dit
que c'était à elle de faire la démarche
de hospitaliser son fils c'est aussi une
autre manière de refiler la
responsabilité et puis combien même oui
il y a une faille nous sommes moi je
préfère dire et être fier de notre
démocratie et notre État de droit et
dire que malheureusement on l'a raté
mais la France vous l'avez rappelé on en
rate très très peu et de en MOS plutôt
que dire ah oui parce que il est fou
parce que ce
par a des victimes qu' fa sûr et que
tout le monde respecte ici évidemment on
reviendra sur l'état de la menace un peu
plus tard Mathieu on va se pencher sur
les réactions de l'exécutif après cet
attentat de J pensais en découvrant le
le tweet de la première ministre
Elizabeth borne posté dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche quelques 3 heur après
l'attaque et qui s'achève sur ces mots
nous ne céderons rien face au terrorisme
jamais nous ne céderons rien quatre mots
déjà prononcés par la même ellisabeth
borne au lendemain de de l'assassinat de
Dominique Bernard à haras c'était le le
14 octobre quatre mots déjà prononcés
par Emmanuel Macron lui aussi lors de
l'hommage rendu au pèreamel en juillet
2021 mais aussi 2 mois plus tôt lors de
l'attaque qui coûta la vie à Stéphanie
montfermé fonctionnaire de police au
commissariat de rambbouillet ou encore
quelques heures après l'attentat à
notred-dame de Nice le 29 octobre 2020 à
chaque fois nous ne cèderons rien h nous
ne céderons ni à la peur ni à la haine
c'était aussi ce que disait François
Hollande lors de la cérémonie aux
Invalides après les attentats du du 13
novembre 2015 nous ne céderons ni à la
menace ni au chantage ça c'est ce que
disait Jacques Chirac le 14 mai 2002 au
lendemain de l'attentat de karashi qui
provoqua la mort de 11 de nos
compatriotes et a vous entendre c'est
une phrase qui finit par perdre de son
sens elle est paradoxale cette phrase
parce qu'en même temps ces quatre mots
il marquent une fermeté une volonté
presque une résistance comme un écho au
we shall never surrender de de Winston
churchield en 1940z dans la guerre
asymétrique que nous livent les
djihadistes sur notre sol et dont
l'objectif c'est de fracturer notre
société et ben cette petite phrase
risonne comme un démenti au terrorisme
même dans la douleur même dans les
froids le pays et la République reste et
resteront debout défendant pied à pied
le terrain de nos principes et de nos
valeurs mais ces quatre
mots nous ne céderons rien ben il
raisonne de plus en plus comme une
oraison funèbre de voir un manthra du
pouvoir les lendemains de drame une de
ces phrases réflexes dont la puissance
olique s'érode à force de répétition et
revit peu à peu on passe de la
résistance à une forme d'aveux
d'impuissance parce que chaque attentat
soulevant les mêmes interrogations et
provoquant les mêmes réactions et ben
ces quatre mots ils ont perdu leur
caractère performatif avec le temps
c'est qu'ils ne découragent pas les
terroristes chacun son aperçoit et il ne
rassure plus vraiment les Français pire
il se retourne désormais contre ceux qui
les prononcent transformant notre
résilience en impatience impatience
constate d'impuissance c'est ce que je
retiens Antoine jardin est-ce que nos
gouvernements sont condamnés à à à ce
constat d'impuissance ou est-ce qu'il y
a une autre politique peut-être de plus
long terme qui pourrait changer la donne
inverser ce sentiment alors il y a
beaucoup d'enjeux on a fait un peu tout
ce qu'on pouvait sur le volet de la
sécurité mais il y a beaucoup d'enjeux
sur les autres aspects notamment sur le
fait de réduire le vivier et réduire
l'impact idéologique du djihadisme sur
les sociétés occidentales donc ça passe
par l'éducation ça passe aussi par le
monde de l'entreprise ça passe par le
monde du travail et donc dans tous ces
autres domaines il y a un enjeu pour
savoir comment est-ce qu'on est vigilant
collectivement et comment est-ce qu'on
diffuse des grilles de lecture qui
rendent les Français CAPA de faire face
à l'impact la tentative de
déstabilisation donc on peut plus
chercher une logique de vaccination des
sociétés démocratiques face à la
pression qu'exercent les djihadistes que
dans l'idée que il y aura plus jamais
d'attentat parce que le djihadistme
c'est un phénomène structurel de long
terme dans 5 ans 10 ans 15 ans 20 ans il
y aura toujours du djihadisme et il
frappera toujours les sociétés
occidentales donc ça doit être un enjeu
de long terme qui nous animer mais alors
pour que ça parce que vous dit 5 ans 10
ans 20 ans pour que ça s'arrête quand
quoi c'est en jeu de long terme donc
c'est quoi c'est une c'est c'est quand
on ajuse sur la culture ça veut dire
quoi c'est dans les écoles c'est c'est
dans d'autres pays les deux c'est ce qui
se passe dans société française et dès
le plus jeune âge où il y a des enjeux
de formation des jeunes enfants et on
sait qu'aujourd'hui dans certaines
familles il y a des enfants qui
grandissent dans des atmosphères qui
sont des atmosphères de haine et de
confrontation et ça pose de graves
problèmes on a notamment les enfants
pire des cas de familles qui reviennent
de Syrie où il y a des enjeux de prise
en charge comment est-ce qu'on fait pour
éduquer ces enfants qui ont connu ces
circonstances on est on est des des des
des familles des parents d'origine
iranienne qui ne sont pas musulmans qui
sont venus en France qui ont fuit le
régime Mola qui sont pas musulmans et
leur fils se radicalis alors c'est pas
forcément toujours le cas mais il y a
une gamme de situation mais ça prouve
aussi que il y a une influence de la
propagande il y a une influence des
réseaux inter relationnels et ça peut
être parfois en détenenstion c'est
parfois dans le monde scolaire c'est
parfois dans le quartier donc on voit
bien l'importance de l'environnement
social dans lequel évoluent les
individus comment est-ce qu'ils
construisent leur rapport à la société
et à la politique ça c'est quelque chose
qui explique ces enjeux là il y a aussi
la question internationale parce qu'on
sait que par exemple la situation au
Sahel aujourd'hui se dégrade très
sensiblement sur le plan de la menace
djihadiste et ça va avoir des
répercussions pour les pays européens
samen Maou vous qui effectivement en
défendant les victimes avaient accès au
au au profil de ces de de ces
terroristes est-ce que vous êtes
pessimiste c'estàd sur le fait que même
si effectivement on réussi à déjouer
beaucoup d'attentats bah il faut qu'on
se prépare à vivre des journées comme
celle-ci encore encore pendant de
longues années en fait je ne suis pas
pessimiste mais je suis réaliste
aujourd'hui comme vous l'avez évoqué
monsieur le terrorisme s'adapte à notre
société à notre rythme de vie à notre
mode de vie le le le terrorisme évolue
et malheureusement j'ai tendance très
souvent à répéter cette phrase c'est que
nous avons un train de retard par
rapport au terrorisme parce que il
s'adapte euh encore une une fois euh la
démocratie n'est pas un frein parce que
euh je préfère euh qu'on réponde par des
méthodes démocratiqu à des personnes euh
qui qui sont dans la dans une idéologie
euh fondamentaliste terroriste islamiste
plutôt que de de de de se comporter de
la même manière queeux donc euh et puis
euh ce qui est important euh c'est de de
de parler de de des des manières et de
la méthode qui est globale de lutte
contre le terrorisme vous avez dit
d'amot le euh le le volet international
mais vous savez dans euh différents
attent différents attentats et face à la
cour d'assise spécialement composé nous
nous sommes nous étions confrontés euh à
la fois les magistrats ainsi que les les
les les avocats des deux bords à
l'absence de coopération judiciaire
entre les États le l'attentat de Nice
2016 malheureusement la Tunisie n'a pas
coopéré on en fait le terroriste
commençait euh son histoire commencé en
2016 alors que non c'est tout à fait par
hasard lors de la présence en tant que
témoin de son père qu'on a su que son
père était condamné et et il était en en
lien avec un un groupe terroriste et ce
que jeux dire ça veut dire qu'il été
impossible de remonter de retracer son
histoire par manque de collaboration des
autorités tunisiennes et et plusieurs
attentats dans l'instruction est en
cours aujourd'hui nous sommes bloqués
parce que la coopération internationale
ne joue pas le jeu et et je ne veux pas
reprendre ce que vous avez dit mais une
lutte contre le terrorisme c'est une
lutte contre qui s'organise sur tous les
Francs tous les Francs alors on on a
évoqué rapidement et on va y consacrer
quelques minutes la la question
effectivement de la radicalisation sur
les réseaux sociaux ou sur internet la
sphère internet en général je vous
propose d'entendre ce que le procureur
antiterroriste a a rappelé hier le cette
allégeance à l'état islamique écoute
les premières investigations ont permis
de mettre en évidence que l'auteur des
faits avait enregistrer une vidéo avant
de passer à
l'acte dans ce film s'exprimant en
langue arabe il se présentait comme
étant abouala
alkorassani ce qui constitue une
référence à l'organisation terroriste
état islamique agissant actuellement à
partir de
l'Afghanistan lors de cette vidéo il
prêtait allégance à l'état islamique il
apportait son soutien au djihadiste
agissant dans différentes zones
notamment en Afrique en Irak en Syrie au
Sinaï au Yémen au corassan ou encore au
Pakistan cette vidéo était notamment
mise en ligne sur son compte x ex
Twitter dont un premier examen faisait
aussi apparaître de nombreuses
publications sur le Hamas Gaza ou plus
généralement la Palestine Jérôme clche
donc c'est les les moyens de
surveillance c'estd queil y a une
publication comme celle-là al on n' pas
réussi à trouver cet après-midi si
c'était quelques minutes quelques heures
avant le le le passage à l'acte mais il
y a pas là une une piste à creuser pour
justement améliorer encore réduire un
peu le c'est ces trous dans la raquette
dont on parlait bah si vous voulez ces
moyens de surveillance là et les
résultats de ces moyens de surveillance
c'est ce qui est directement prévu dans
la loi 2015 sur l' enseement est repris
dans la loi 2021 avec cette
autonomatisation ce que je vous disais
de surveillance des contenus
informatiques des
métadonnées système par moteur de
recherche qui permett d'automatiser ça
et de faire en sorte que ce qui est
intercepté sur le plan informatique et
bien soit totalement exploité de façon à
ce qu'il ressorte ce type de contenu là
donc si vous voulez en matière de savoir
on peut toujours faire mieux bien sûr
mais là encore une fois on savait ce qui
est là où j'is dire le la marge de
manœuvre en terme de de progrès est
faible c'est parce que la stratégie même
de l'État islamique repose sur une
revendication implicite de tout acte
décentralisé qui se revendiquerait de
l'État islamique acte décentralisé
perpétré le plus souvent par des profils
dont euh la
psychologie la santé mentale est
questionner voire même documenter et euh
et en en défaillance totale donc si vous
voulez il y a effectivement euh une
stratégie de l'État islamique et
d'autres terroristes qui permet en fait
finalement d'affaiblir euh la lutte que
l'on peut avoir contre le terrorisme en
ce que elle se doit après de cibler des
individus qui sont d'une certaine
manière un peu isolé au sens où et c'est
là où c'est important et c'est là où la
théorie du du loup solitaire se survit
au sens où ils ne sont pas engagés dans
des attentats de grand templeur il y
aurait desfillances du renseignement
s'il y avait un autre bat ou parmi ou
raison il y aurait défillance là si vous
voulez la défaillance en matière de
renseignement elle est vraiment tenue
s'il en est une faire il encore beaucoup
de choses mais mat j'ai juste une
question parce que la mention alini elle
est pointue quand même forte c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on trouve en deux clics
sur Google c'est quelqu'un qui a des
liens ou qui a forcément une vraie
connexion
avec on le voit bien la structure de la
revendication signe en fait une très
bonne maîtrise et qui est cohérente avec
le fait que c'est quelqu'un qui a un
engagement de long terme dans des
groupes djihadistes en contact avec des
djihadistes de haut niveau international
et que du coup c'est une logique qui
pointe que il y a toujours une activité
de ces groupeslà même si elle a été
fortement réprimée leur visibilité est
plus faible et aujourd'hui sur Twitter
on a encore des contenus implicitement
jihadistes parce que c'est plus
difficile de de le faire explicitement
sur des plateformes occidentales mais
sur beaucoup de sites internet on trouve
encore de la propagande dialiste en
ligne de façon importante et elle touche
la jeunesse française par le biais des
applications des messages des réseaux
sociaux il y a un enjeu à décrypter et à
donner les moyens de la résilience de la
jeunesse face à cette propagande ça
reste quelque chose à conrire au
l'ucation c'est l'éducation mais c'est
aussi pouvoir aller sur ces contenuslà
et pas juste dire on fait une minute de
silence et après tout va rentrer dans le
rang ça veut dire qu'il faut accepter
qu'avec les jeunes français on va aller
expliquer ce que c'est que la propagande
trouver ceux qui ont g regardé par
exemple les vidéos après haras et leur
dire pourquoi vous l'avez fait discuz
avec eux ces vidéos elles ont été
montrées sur la plupart des chaînes
d'information donc elles ont été vues
mais qu'est-ce qu'on a comme discours
pour expliquer qu'est-ce qu'on apprend à
décrypter des images des codes des
signifiants de cette violence là on a
besoin d'avoir une génération de
citoyens qui sont capables de comprendre
qui sont capables de faire face à ces
enjeuxl oui un levier là aussi c'est se
montrer beaucoup plus ferme et beaucoup
plus
cooheritif à l'égard des plateformes des
applications des réseaux sociaux qui
sont souvent pronts à chasser le moindre
le moindre signe j'allais dire d'un tat
au bon MS oui et qui finalement sur des
pH onisser passerement exactement voilà
donc là il y a peut-être une action à
mener effectivement mais pour le coup
elle ne se pas suite pas au niveau du
renseignement à par autre piste avec la
question de la rétention de STI on va en
parler tout de suite avec Steve Jourdain
qui va nous nous rejoindre sur ce
plateau bonsoir Steve bienvenue à vous
plusieurs responsables politiques qui
demande donc la mise en place de
rétention de sûreté pour ces détenus
condamnés pour terrorisme l'idée n'est
pas vraiment nouvelle hein non c'est une
idée simple il s'agit de laisser
certains individus dangereux en prison
après qu'ils aient purgé leur peine
c'est une mesure proposée par une partie
de la droite depuis plusieurs années
elle a reçu ce weekend la bénédiction de
Manuel Vals écoutz moi je pense que
c'est une mesure qui peut avoir du sens
après comme toute mesure législative
elle va devoir être appliquée d'une
manière ou d'une autre soit par les
services de police et évidemment par les
magistrats voilà à l'heure actuelle on
compte 80 libérations par an de détenus
condamnés pour terrorisme islamiste
alors cette rétention de sûreté elle
existe déjà dans notre droit on peut
garder certaines personnes en prison
après leur peine oui mais seulement
certaines personnes condamnées pour
certains crimes et dans des conditions
très précises à l'heure actuelle la
rétention de sûreté ne s'applique pas au
condamnés pour terrorisme il est
possible de retenir des personnes qui
ont déjà purgé leur peine mais cela ne
concerne que des individus qui ont
effectué au moins 15 ans 15 ans de
réclusion criminelle pour certains
crimes comme assassiné meurtre aggravé
ou encore acte de barbarie il faut aussi
que ces personnes présentent une
particulière dangerosité caractérisée
par une probabilité très élevée de
récidive en l'espèce Thomas l'assaillant
du pont birakem avait été condamné en
2016 à seulement seulement entre
guillemis an de prison pour association
de malfaiteurs en vue de préparation
d'un acte de terrorisme il n'entrait
donc pas dans cette catégorie alors on
l'a évoqué il existe aujourd'hui un
dispositif de surveillance pour ceux qui
sortent de prison oui les terroristes
qui sortent de prison qui sont considéré
comme particulièrement dangereux peuvent
faire l'objet d'un suivi spécifique
c'est ce qu'on appelle des mesures de
sûreté elles sont prévues dans une loi
adopté en 2021 ces individus peuvent
avoir plusieurs obligations qui leur
sont imposées par exemple obligation de
pointer au commissariat devoir d'obtenir
l'autorisation d'un juge pour changer de
résidence encore l'interdiction d'entrer
en contact avec certaines personnes
l'obligation de suivre une prise en
charge en vue d'une réinsertion ou
encore la nécessité de porter un brass
bracelet électronique toutes ces mesures
peuvent durer jusqu'à 1 an elles sont
renouvelables jusqu'à 5 ans certains
élus notamment au Sénat demande
aujourd'hui à ce que ces dispositifs
soient durcis notamment en en prévision
des Joo 2024 qui vont se s'ouvrir dans
moins de 8 mois merci beaucoup Steve
pour toutes ces ces informations alors
on est vraiment au cœur de notre débat
sur la capacité de nos démocraties à se
défendre face à cette menace terroriste
rétention de sûreté Samia mactouf est-ce
que c'est une une solution pour
améliorer le système puisque on
l'utilise déjà dans dans certains cas
pour certains crimes bon voilà est-ce
qu'il faut là si on reprend le cas
particulier 15 ans est-ce qu'il faut
l'appliquer aussi pour des crimes des
condamnations moins lourdes mais mais
avec toujours cette question de notre de
notre droit de notre État de droit tout
à fait cette privation de liberté
au-delà de des des années purgées pour
un délit ou un crime jugé par une
instance judiciaire est tout à fait
possible euh maintenant il faut
toujours je voudrais juste dire que nous
sommes liés par un principe de la non
rétroactivité de la loi et cette
disposition ne n'aurait pas pu
s'appliquer à ce terroriste puisque il a
été jugé il a purgé sa peine et il
n'avait on avait pas prévu parce qu'il
faut que ces dispositions soi prévu dans
le texte même de la décision donc encore
une fois ce n'est pas un frein mais mais
à un moment donné on est obligé de de
respecter la loi parce que c'est ce qui
permet de le respect de de l'égalité
et bien sûr ça fonctionne et et j'ai
envie de dire que elle fonctionne très
très bien pour un autre crime qui est
qui concerne les pédophiles aujourd'hui
c'est un moyen très
efficace puisque il y a une mesure de
soin et nous avons suffisamment de recul
et on peut tout à fait s'en inspirer et
appliquer la loi avec les cadres le
cadre prévu par notre droit positif
franç Jard votre avis un enjeu qui est
important c'est que si on estime que la
peine initiale est pas assez importante
ou qu'elle n'est pas possiblement assez
importante dans le code pénal il faut
modifier le code pénal mais là on est en
train de faire des dérogations à des
dispositions qui sont la décision de la
justice ça que je dis on est dans un
état de droit il a été condamné à telle
t telle durée de peine on va pas
indéfiniment la prolonger pas
indéfiniment c'est ce qui s'est passé
historiquement de choisir de durcir les
peines d'élever le quantum de peine ça
ça pe être une décision c'est une
décision à prend démocratiquement et qui
me paraît à mon sens plus cohérente que
l'extension de mesures répressives
au-delà de la peined qu'on est plus dans
nos principes démocratiques en faisant
ça qu'en prolongeant je dis indéfiniment
je caricature un peu la peinea dans
l'arbitraire Mathieu et surtout faut se
garder de de de l'instrumentalisation
politique qui est faite d'une telle
proposition parce que les Français quand
ils entendent on va forcer les condamnés
qui ont plus leur peine à rester en
rétention de sûrté ils ont l'impression
que tout le monde va être mis au trou si
j'ose dire de façon indéfin ce n'est pas
le cas faut rappeler quand même que ce
sont des décisions qui sont collégiales
euh donc là on voit bien qu'il y a eu
des avis en tout cas qui ont divergé en
tout cas qui n'ont pas forcément été sur
la même longueur d'onde entre entre les
médecins c'est des c'est des décisions
qui sont contradictoires heureusement on
est dans un état de droit donc le le
condamné qui a purgé sa peine a le droit
d'être défendu puis ce sont des des
c'est là une question que je vous pose
mais dans ma mémoire ce sont des des
mesures qui sont bornées dans le temps
enfin c'est un an renouvelable et alors
je ne sais pas si c'est renouvelable à
vitam etternam mais mais c'est pas non
plus c'est pas non plus indéfiniment on
peut envoyer quelqu'un de façon
strictement encadré par la loi h mais on
pourrait durcir un peu le dispositif
c'est ce que c'est ce que j'entends en
tout cas sur sur le quantum des peen ce
que dire par là c'est que sur le quantum
des peenes on voit bien c'est une
appréciation de la justice sur la base
des pièces complètes du dossier et sur
l'ensemble de la procédure de définir un
quantom de peine qui est pertinent il il
y a un autre par vous interrompis un
autre une autre donnée que que Steve
Jourdin a donné dans son dans sa
chronique c'est le le nombre de détenus
condamnés pour terrorisme libérés en
moyenne chaque année on est à autour de
de 80 euh vous avez en partie répondu à
cette question Jérôme kèche mais euh on
on a les moyens de tous les surveiller
80 par an et donc chaque année il y en a
80 qui s'ajoute à ceux qui sont là
depuis depuis quelques années fich s de
euh de dangerosité élevée c'est de 1 à
16 c'est 20 fonctionnaires donc euh
voilà ce serait 20 fonctionnaires pour
une surveillance 24 24 24h sur 24 donc
je ne sais pas si on a les moyens de de
de par de pratiquer ça après là aussi
c'est un choix de société rond à la
question c'est un choix de société après
de dimensionner des moyens de sécurité
pour se donner cet objectif là et là là
je m'exprime en tant que citoyen et ce
choix de société là est-ce qu'il faut
effectivement j'allais dire tomber dans
le piège tendu par le terrorisme
d'ailleurs il faudrait peut-être dire
les terrorisme et voir à quel type de
terrorisme on a on a affaire islamisme
radical oui mais en encore une fois
quand il y a une composante
psychiatrique importante liée au fou
solitaire et non pas à des du terrorisme
de masse comme le Bataclan c'est deux
physionomies complètement différentes
qui appellent sans doute des réponses
différentes même s'il y a un Tron commun
en terme de renseignement mais après sur
les réponses que l'on peut faire pour
arriver d'une certaine manière à prévoir
à préempter et à faire en sorte de
réduire le risque à zéro il y a
certainement un distingo à avoir voilà
mais en tant que choix de société
faut-il sombrer dans le piège qui
consiste finalement à renier toujours
plus sur notre État de droit pour lutter
contre un ennemi qui veut précisément
mettre fin à l'état de droit voyez bien
sûr dernier thème dans notre débat on
l'a évoqué aussi la la perspective des
Jeux olympiques de de Paris c'est dans
moins de 8 mois et forcément cet
attentat ravive les inquiétudes on
écoute la ministre des Sports et des
Jeux Olympiques Amélie oua carerin il y
a aussi des dispositifs de sécurité qui
vont être très réhaussés pendant les
Jeux Olympiques et par olympique
typiquement l'endroit où s'est passé cet
attentat horrible euh correspond à un
périmètre silt sécurité intérieure et
loi terrorisme dans lequel on a la
possibilité d'avoir des contrôles
extrêmement poussés des fouilles des
contrôles d'identité donc ce sont des
périmètres qui sont hautement sécurisés
nous avons toute une série de moyens qui
sont prévus jusqu'à des d mineurs des
équipes cinophiles pour la lutte
antidrone la lutte antiterroriste nous
sommes équipés sur tout cela et il y a
aussi tout le dispositif autour des
périmètres de sécurité que le préfet de
police a évoqué notamment ce périmètre
silt mais aussi des périmètres rougge et
bleu qui vont permettre de sécuriser en
profondeur la
zone quel est l'état de la la menace
aujourd'hui Antoine jardin est-ce que
parce que là vous disiez terrorisme
lowcost bon comment vous l'analysez ça
avec vu le nombre de de d'attentats
potentiellement déjoués dans notre pays
on sait qu'il y a une propagande
diadiste qui est active de long terme et
moi je suis plus inquiet des périodes
pendant lesquelles on considère que ça
va mieux et qu'il faut être moins
vigilant ou que c'est plus sur le haut
des priorité parce que je pense que
c'est dans ces périodes là qu'on prend
du retard par rapport aux organisations
là on sait qu'on est dans des
circonstances on va faire très attention
donc il y aura un
dispositif particulièrement
renforcéou oui et et sur et sur l'idée
alors je reviens à la à l'enjeu des des
rétentions de de sûreté Sam mactouf le
fait de prolonger finalement ses
rétentions de sûreté systém ement mais
je pense qu'il faudrait là aussi sans
doute passer par la loi euh pour passer
après aller après les Jeux Olympiques
voyez ce que je dis d'abord on pourra
pas
prolonger sans respecter le cadre légal
qui est bien décrit et puis pour donc on
est quoi dans la gesticulation politique
quand quand quand des responsables ça sû
bien sûr bien sûr de tempant que ceux
qui sont déjà sortis ils ne seront pas
encore une fois en application de la non
rétroactivité de la loi soumis à cette
privation est possible mais qui ne
l'urait pas applicable ouais Jérôme cl
l'état de la menace qu'est-ce que vous
en dites vous aujourd'hui bah le
terrorisme c'est déjà du lowcost par
définition en terme de stratégie donc là
si vous voulez dans ce ce terrorisme que
je qualifierais du terrorisme à la
personne comme il y a du service à la
personne vous voyez où ça cible une
personne sans volonté de frapper dans la
masse parce que impossible avec des
armes rudimentaire et effectivement là
on est j'allais dire à la limite du
modèle de l'attentat terroriste et ce
qui est d'ailleurs la difficulté parce
que à la fois on peut le qualifier de
terroriste et ça permet tout un arsenal
et en effet il y a un fond islamisme
radical qui je le justifie mais en même
temps il y a une dimension psychiatrique
donc cet état de la menace fait planer
en fait un spectre sur l'ensemble des
grands événement parce qu'effectivement
et là il frappe dans pardon hein je je
je on peut pas on pe frapper dans la
masse pardon pardonnez-moi mais il avait
l'intention de frapper dans la masse
dans la masse qu je dis dans la masse
c'est frapper 100 ou 1000 personnes
c'est pas
dans une rue voilà il fait dans le
quartier de la Tourel alors aujourd'hui
on est au tout début de l'enquête il a à
peine répondu au aux enquêteurs il a
simplement dit qu'il avait agi seul et
on le saura dans les prochaines heures
si c'est vrai ou pas bon bref mais
est-ce qu' est-ce qu' est-ce qu'il y a
une un choix de de cibler le quartier de
La Tour Effel voilà probablement parce
que mais probablement mais ça demande
pas de travail cibler le quartier de La
Tour effffel c'est dire il y a un
symbole c'est la tour Efel et un un un
comment
tourist le vrai sujet c'est que la
menace qui plan c'est que dans le cadre
des grands événements n'importe qui peut
être touché à n'importe quel endroit et
l'idée c'est même pas la concentration
de personne ça peut-être quelqu'un qui
traverse c'est là où est le danger il un
dispositif substantiel mis en pas
seulement les grands événems depuis 2014
la propagande de DA vise la tour les
attentats du Bataclan ont été précédé
d'explosion au Stade de France donc il y
a pas d'enjeux spécifique par rapport à
dynamique de long il avait la photo de
la torfel sur le le téléphone portable
de l'assillant du terroriste merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat je
vais rappeler on cache le titre de votre
livre la prospective stratégique c'est
aux éditions euh Herman je vous dis à
bientôt sur euh sur public scénat